it's some inside dirt one time i was
reading a cosmo there's a full page
article on how to go down on a woman
properly
it's like this should be in like guns
and ammo or field of stream
sports illustrated teach us late we want
to please god damn you got fake
eyelashes hair extensions spanx
foundation you should know what i'm
thinking i even know you [ __ ] look
like
that's why it's weird when a woman's
like you wanna have sex with me you
gotta get to know me first get to know
you you're wearing three pounds of
jewelry clown makeup and a hole in the
fart for four weeks
i don't know who the hell you are
that's why it's so important to have sex
it's not because we're horny psycho
animals we are but it's important
because you finally see behind the
curtain for the first time and it's
glorious ladies your hair is messed up
you're naked yelling out filthy
obscenities like damn who's this
your friend calls hey it took a month
but you banged sarah how was it great i
finally met her
he's like oh man all right we'll come
over we'll talk about them like i can't
she won't let me leave
thanks a lot i'm kevin hart you guys are
great what a crowd